there are two types of intrauterine
devices hormonal iuds
and a copper iud
to prevent pregnancy a doctor places an
iud inside a woman's uterus with the
string hanging down inside her vagina
both types of iud cause mild
inflammation of the uterine lining
which releases immune cells and
chemicals that kill sperm
hormonal iuds also contain a synthetic
type of progesterone called
levonorgestrel
levanorgestrel mainly prevents pregnancy
by thickening the mucus inside the
cervix which prevents sperm from
entering the uterus
it also prevents the uterine lining from
thickening so it is less likely to
receive a fertilized egg